mallem dessus bon soir le doute mail
intime conviction tôt ce matin après
seulement quatre heures de délibéré les
jurés de la cour d'assises de la seine
maritime ont condamné pour meurtre avec
préméditation
jean marc deperrois 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle son avocat sa famille et au
delà considère qu'il y à l' erreur
judiciaire
dominique verdeilhan ludovic fossard je
pense est rentré avec mon mari
au lendemain de la condamnation de jean
marc deperrois son épouse parle de
verdict de la honte
l'acquittement lui semblait évident mais
cette nuit douze jurés en ont décidé
autrement
j'ai plein j'ai plein je voudrais pas
être à leur place parce que moi j'ai la
tête haute
mon mari est innocent on va l'aider on
va le soutenir
je voudrais pas être à la place des
jurés pour eux je pense que toute leur
vie ça va les poursuivre j'espère qui
sait pas ce qu'il se rende compte de ce
qu'ils ont fait absente au moment du
verdict sylvie tocqueville l'ami de jean
marc deperrois elle ne s'explique pas
cette condamnation
vingt ans de prison je n'y crois pas
je ne crois pas je suis désolé je pense
que j'ai suffisamment d'arguments sur ce
sujet là pendant cinq heures
jeudi un journal
emilie est morte par erreur la véritable
cible c'était moi a soutenu jean michel
tocqueville au procès les jurés lui ont
donné raison
je suis légaliste je pense que je n'ai
pas de commentaires à faire asseoir des
signaux pense qu'ils avaient les
éléments vous allez tous les éléments je
pense que il n'ya pas l'erreur
judiciaire sous protection des gendarmes
depuis ce matin la maison des parents
d'emilie cette nuit corinne la mer était
prise à partie par le public dans la
cour du palais alors que les victimes
étaient montrés du doigt al marri de
perroy et est soutenu par la parole dans
la nuit deux adolescents clame
l'innocence d'un condamné l'innocence de
leur père aujourd'hui je suis devant
vous pour affirmer que mon père et yéo
ce temps il me l'a juré plusieurs fois
et je le crois je suis fier de lui
effroyable procès incroyable verdict qui
selon m lienemann l'avocat de la défense
ne peut pas réconcilier les français
avec leur justice
cette nuit un homme a été condamné et le
mystère de la josacine demeure à retenir
encore dans la pub est une série
d'attentats en corse à la mi journée
étaient visés les directions
départementales de l'équipement
d'ajaccio et de bastia ainsi qu'à local
de france télécommunications un autre
engin avait explosé l'année dernière
près de la gendarmerie de l'état ou
sud-ouest du bastia fait divers de
personnes ont été abattues à coups de
chevrotine et deux autres blessés
dimanche matin gassin près de saint
tropez
il s'agirait d'un règlement de compte
familial le meurtrier un homme de 64 ans
il pourrait s'agir d'un différend sur un
partage
en bref encore poursuite de la grève des
gardiens de nuit du musée du louvre ils
ont empêché l'accès aux musées
aujourd'hui encore à l'étranger le drame
algérien selon l'un de nos confrères de
la presse écrite algérienne des
chauffeurs de taxi ont découvert sur le
bas côté d'une route 18 est humaine le
massacre a eu lieu dans un village des
hauts plateaux du centre du pays où
vivent de nombreux nomades plusieurs
meurtres de berger et ont eu lieu ces
dernières semaines en sierra leone une
élection pluraliste avait eu lieu en
1996 un coup d'état renversent le régime
du président
légende kaba celui ci est ensuite dans
ce pays de la côte ouest de l'afrique
vive 4 millions et demi d'habitants
l'afghanistan d'un col stratégique qui
commande l'accès au nord du pays est
tombée aux mains des talibans
après le ralliement d'un chef de guerre
à cette ministre islamiste désormais des
talibans contrôlent plus de 80% du pays
depuis leur victoire à kaboul en
septembre dernier le sport avec la
formule 1 et la victoire de jacques
villeneuve dans le grand prix d'espagne
laurent frédéric bollée un podium comme
ça on en rêvait presque bis 9 panis
alesi un canadien francophone de france
l espagne à sourire disney des trois
seuls pilotes dont le français est la
langue maternelle
un départ pour le moins spectaculaire vu
depuis l'intérieur de la voiture de
michael schumacher qui passe directement
de la 7e à la 3e place mais ensuite un
scénario limpide
jacques villeneuve est parti devant on
ne le reverra quasiment plus troisième
victoire en six courses cette saison
ils retrouvent la tête au championnat
mais derrière c'est la sensation
olivier panis parti 12e seulement sur sa
presque renom tout le monde est au prix
de dépassements négocier à 3 110
km/heure parvient à arracher la deuxième
place
le voici même 3e au championnat du monde
avec 15 points
on n'avait pas eu pas mal de problèmes
en qualifications ce que nos pneus a été
assez dur pour ce grand prix mais on
savait qu'en course on pourrait essayer
de marquer des points
donc tout le team a travaillé pour la
course je suis très content ils ont fait
un travail fantastique j'espère que ça
va continuer tout au long de la saison
pas de fumée sans feu un autre français
s'illustrent jean alesi revient en grâce
avec une troisième place méritée devant
schumacher s'il vous plaît de quoi
remettre du baume au coeur à un pilote
mal en point depuis le début de la
saison le championnat était très dur
pour nous mais maintenant bon ça va
donner un peu d'oxygène à tout le monde
marie curie et p1
on va voir ce qu'il va se passer pour la
en tout cas dès dimanche comme ça pour
la formule heure française
on en redemande
le retraité eric cantona continue de
susciter les enthousiasme et curiosité
il participait aujourd'hui à lille au
jubilé des frères planque les anciens du
losc le midi olympique sporting club
pas moins de onze télévisions étrangères
et toute la presse britannique était
représentée avant que ce match ne
commence
et puis notez que demain c'est le début
des internationaux de france de tennis à
roland garros le match du jour opposera
fabrice santoro à pete sampras fin de
cette édition est courte et merci de
nous avoir suivis dans un instant bien
sûr vous retrouverez la soirée spéciale
consacrée à cette élection législative
anticipée
tu as france 2
à